why does this happen well there's this
interesting feature on Google that
allows you to reverse image search stuff
you can input an image into Google and
then Google will search similar images
to that image I want to try that right
now and see what weird results we get
we've rested we've regained a little bit
of our mana we're gonna see if we can
summon Nico right now what do you think
guys
[Music]
and you had a man renowned I am oh man I
can't edit for the rest of the day so
you're saying I can take a picture of my
knocks on your brain
search my image upload an image to
choose file you should be able to should
find like images selfie our selfie oh it
described it and describes it oh that's
interesting
there's similar images here's a good
dude in the same space the same blue
beam in the background whoa whoa let's
be real it's like a pseudo quartered
digital office that is so weird how it
identified the blue beam and here's the
on mosque apparently I look a little bit
like Elon Musk
dude Christian Bale is Wow more burly
dudes and Ben Affleck stick your face in
this camera and see what it thinks your
biggest trait is dry well hi wouldn't
identify driving what let's get weird
with this oh hey hey I missed you it's
it's been a little while I have been
neck deep with my neck being up here in
this anime card video I have been
getting a lot of blue screens and I'm
still getting closer my grandpa's cars
just crashed for a moment the internet
go out great
great I don't want to say that I had
another blue screen on camera right now
but I did we just tripled our render
times did I just crash my computer it
has been a tremendous amount of work
it's really ambitious over-ambitious in
fact kind of to the point of being scary
sam had his beautiful little baby boy
and so he's gone for like the next month
and he was straining to get everything
basically done that he was trying to do
one time and then he got it all down
he's like alright now is the piece that
was that was so I can leave frame but
what that leaves me with is trying to
finish the entirety of the rest of the
project there are over 120 visual
effects shots which to put into
perspective is twice the number of
effect shots in Jurassic Park yeah bad
comparison and don't leave
about please if things went 100%
flawlessly it would still take a decent
mint of time to do this video the
problem is that I'm constantly running
into issues everyone who has ever dealt
with software has dealt with it crashing
before sometimes it'll like freeze up on
a frame and I have like a 12-hour render
going all night but it just stops about
a third of the way through because it's
like oh this one frame has just taken
years and then other times are almost
amusing but infuriating at the same time
because it's like why does this happen
for instance this shot right here okay
okay to preface what I'm about to talk
to you about I'm actually going to
preview pre though I'm actually going to
preview a shot from the video you're
about to get sneak peek about to get a
sneaky peeky I'm just gonna hit play I'm
ready like I'm actually pretty happy
with how it's looking the environment
we've toned down enough that it's not
too distractingly bad quality I have way
too many street lights in the scene to
make any sense but they look cool and
the cars are reflecting lights off of
the from the sky and the lights and the
headlights I was pretty pleased with
this until I got to look and I was like
what happens here the railing disappears
look at this you see like for just some
reason the the railing just cuts out I
had started rendering this shot on my
computer but then it locked up on one of
those frames while I'm working since Sam
is gone
I'm gonna finish rendering the shot on
his computer what I didn't realize when
I opened this file on his computer the
guardrail I should I should Superman the
guardrail it should be there I bought a
3d model of a guardrail I multiplied to
so several times long
I used a modifier called path deform the
railing will go wherever I put a path I
just had a path going along this entire
length of the road the side of it so
that a railing can go wherever I want it
really flexible and it makes it really
easy to set up shots the problem is that
even though Sam and I are using the
exact same program his software for some
reason doesn't have the exact same
modifier that I'm using so when I load
up this project file on his camp
ughter it just doesn't load up the the
guardrails if I type in path deform is
right there
but notice how it has a space and if we
go to Sam's computer go to Sam's
computer this computer right here is
currently actually rendering a shot
it's got 30 more hours to go so I'm just
gonna cancel that right now and I'm
gonna resume it after we fill this bit
because it says missing OSM I'm pretty
sure that means missing object space
modifier then okay path deform see that
it's there without a space there's no
space in that path deform right here and
it looks completely different you don't
have nearly as much control it's like I
don't I don't I don't understand why
understand why it's not there
fortunately it's easy to fix we used to
be so much better this already been
rendered the entirety the shot is done
you know there's no reason to redo the
redo this entire 15 hour render that's
the way I have looked this up and I
cannot for the life of me figure out why
there's a difference here why do I have
this modifier when Sam does not we're
both learning 3ds max 2018
we both have updated versions at least
that dot this is fortunately a very
simple simple fix but it's a fix
nonetheless that I've got to do and it's
just kind of annoying if you're on the
50 Nick I want you to be right here on
the 50 come take a look
or doing some effects that typically
require full professional teams are you
coming out that way because I got
bullets at you try it let's see let's
see how our willful gonna fall a little
our what do you want
Oh
all right bring it up slower to your
head in the second I'll just do one more
squid so yeah actually if you could prep
two spoons will be set
I mean at the end of the day we're all
just doing like the Jedi move on
automatic open doors at the grocery
store it's the same guy yeah now surely
you go out then you come back in you
switch the ignition yeah this is it's we
hired some two babies for this job
they're kind of flying a man killing us
just Center on them right there 35 mil
what do we do here today over all right
well man what we're doing right now is
the darkness guy
Oh oh we missed that we missed it I cut
you're right
the real obstacle is getting yelled at
by neighbors and we have a lot to get
through so because right now it's 12
o'clock in fact we've got two hours to
cover the rest of this until the point
I would go
hit him in the face right about to the
process
action done [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh
[Applause]
and that's what we thought of named
Adrienne skirt pulled it in all right
let's get the now just smear that autumn
dudes like neck
am I gonna be in this role it's not in
the mouth a little bit
mine's quick and concise three two one
action clear okay sir
and what was really good
it's like don't worry we got all the
shots of me program anyway
clear yeah thanks dick
clear
[Music]
[Applause]
let's try it like yeah another corner
gonna better cap wow it detected the
baseball cap that's pretty impressive
this is so weird so so Google has a
giant learning AI that just is doing
this constantly you notice how Facebook
will like suggest tags because it knows
what everybody's faces look like now
this is tree up for this I'm 84 percent
masculine
16% feminine and 33 years old that's
actually super close I'm 32
that's really creepy okay let me play
dude you look like David girl a little
bit in the mixer for the wince is
starting in a little bit I fear what
this thing is gonna say it's probably
gonna say I'm like 40 the tech think a
says I'm younger than ego I'm thirty
only wow dude paul weitz I don't know
you don't much anything like him I see
anything fails I'm let's [ __ ] Cooper
[Music]
Hey look at look at the match
percentages they're all like 3% 4%
Matthew McConaughey Bradley Cooper I was
like like the most attractive Hollywood
actors dancers right in the middle is
the prettiest gonna be like 100% man
like this oh is that beard dude you're
[Laughter]
detecting weighs 3400 Dameron in there
Chris Kirkpatrick he's got this
like eh dog that's a high honor well
it's not meant for us this is nuclei are
you next yeah we fed it so much
information today it's so happy with us
we'll probably go up in the algorithm
given how much information it says path
the form it's an effect that I've
applied to this model imagine like a
wiggly worm and then encasing it nice
that's kind of what I'm doing to the
guardrail that's a terrible comparison
and I go to convert to editable poly it
and it now thinks that there are no
effects applied to it those effects have
been now baked into the geometry of the
3d model I can save this open the back
up on Sam's computer and it will show up
and render just fine however the shot
has already been rendered you know
there's no reason to redo this entire 15
hour render it is an absolute waste of
time so fortunately there's a really
cool and easy thing I can do using
octane write it select these two models
octane properties and I can I can
literally select object layer ID can I
change that to two or any number between
0 100 what that does is when it comes
time to rendering this shot he'll octane
render only what is under layer number 2
and it will render the entire scene as
if it's a final render but only deliver
you what you've selected and here's that
guardrail that are rendered out it
rendered so much faster instead an
overnight render took like half an hour
and I was able to just do that during my
lunch break so I rendered out this whole
thing you see these little gaps here
that's where the car is literally in
front of it drop this on top of the
render and I don't have to do any
compositing laid it on top it is
currently off I'm gonna turn it on and
now there's a railing there I literally
virtually 3d printed the perfect puzzle
piece to fit into something that has
already been previously made it's a
really simple fix but it is a few steps
that I had to account for I didn't
realize the problem of having two
different modifiers on two different
computers even though everything else is
the same
I know the livestreams waiting but the
but I love
I know I know go to the line we got okay
hey I gotta wrap this up because we've
got a live stream going and there look
which you can get to next time we do
this live stream if you support us on
patreon picture might help us / the
court or additional